كيف يمر الوقت
ناهيك عن طيور النورس ، أخذناها جميعًا
على الذقن مرة أخرى في عام 2021
ولكن لم يكن هناك أي شخص أكثر حرفيًا من هذا
المراهق الذي يركب لقطة الربيع على
شاطئ جيرسي ، كان هناك الكثير
للاحتفال أوه
وتوم برادي فعل ذلك من خلال الجرأة على عدم الذهاب
في أعماق المياه مع كأس لومباردي الفائق ، كان
هناك رجل آخر معروف أيضًا بيديه كان
بيرني ساندرز الذي أصبحت قفازاته عند
الافتتاح واحدة من أولى
الميمات الكبيرة لعام 2021
في أزياء بالنسياغا التي جمعت
الراحة والتعذيب مع
625 دولارًا من معقل التماسيح ذو الكعب العالي.
خذها مرتين تريد أن
ينظر الناس وينظرون مرة أخرى ، نظر رجل ماساتشوستس
وبحث مرة أخرى عن Airpod المفقودة
بعد أن نام باستخدامها في
النهاية ، تم وضع الأشعة السينية في
مريئه وتم استخلاص الصوت
يعمل بشكل مثالي ولكن
للأسف الميكروفون هو  شديد الجاذبية على
الأقل لم يغلق عينيه مثل
هذه المرأة من ميشيغان التي قصدت الوصول
إلى قطرات العين ولكن استخدم غراء الأظافر
بدلاً من
هذه العدسات اللاصقة  لقد أنقذت
رؤيتها ،
ربما تعتقد أنك ترى
دواين مزدوجًا ، وقد اهتز معجبي موسيقى الروك جونسون من
قبل ملازم دورية ألاباما هذا
الذي يبدو وكأنه صخرة ، هل يمكنك شم رائحتها
ولكن
الصخرة تطبخ وعميل الخدمة السرية هذا الذي
يحمي بايدن أصبح فيروسيًا فقط
لكونها ساخنة
جرسًا ميتًا لتوم كروز ،
لم يكن البابا بحاجة إلى حماية من الرجل العنكبوت ،
رجل إيطالي يرتدي ملابس للترفيه عن
الأطفال في المستشفيات ، تجنبت نيكول ريتشي
المستشفى على الرغم من أنها تمكنت
من التقاط شعرها على النار ، انسى
الشموع التي تنفجر نيكول
انفجر مدير برجر كينج وثمانية موظفين
عن طريق الاستقالة علنًا
بهذه العلامة
بينما لم يتوقف رودي جولياني عن
الحلاقة في الأماكن العامة في صالة جون كينيدي في دلتا ،
قال الرجل الذي أطلق المشهد إنني
مسرور ومذعور
يمكن أن يقال عن الجمع  الأطعمة من
حلقات الفاكهة والبيتزا إلى سلطة الفشار إلى
حلوى الذرة
النقانق بالطبع الحيوانات سرقت العرض
المعكرونة الكلب المتنبئ توقع جيدًا أو
سيئًا  أيام من رغبته في الاستيقاظ ، يا
إلهي ، يا إلهي ،
هناك عظام اليوم تقضي إما بالعظام
أو بدون عظام أيام ،
أوه ، إنهيار هزلي ناعم في
العام يذهب إلى هذا الرجل الذي وجده يتجول في
مدينة كانساس ، ميسوري ، قاموا بإزالة ستة
و  نصف رطل من الفراء غير اللامع
كان عليه أن يتعلم المشي مرة أخرى ويقول أصحابه الجدد
إن كل هذا الشعر قد أثر
على ذيله بشكل أساسي في اتجاه واحد ، ثم
هناك
ذيل الغزلان في فرجينيا الذي قفز على
حافلة مدرسية هبطت على طالب نائم
صنعوه  شهدت محطة توقف غير
مجدولة لإسقاطه خارج
2021 بعضًا من guinness غير العادية
يسجل أكبر فم مقاس 5.7 بوصات ، وهو أكبر عدد من
eminem مكدس على بعضه البعض ، وهو
خمسة أشياء يجب أن أعترف بها ، لقد أكلتهم
جميعًا أطول آذان للكلاب حيث يبلغ
قياس آذان
Coonhound 13.38 بوصة  كل واحدة من
خلال المقابلة التي أجريناها ، ظلت
تحدق في الجانب الذي كانت تحدق فيه
في باب زجاجي
بالطبع ، نهاية العام هي وقت رائع
للتأمل الذاتي ، كيف يمكن للآخرين
رؤيتي؟  تسمعني أحكم ،
يمكنني سماعك ، أعتقد أنه مرشح ،
محامي تكساس يستخدم
كمبيوتر مساعده أثناء جلسة استماع يؤذي نفسه وهو
يخرج من القطط ، أنا هنا على قيد الحياة ،
هذا ليس أنا لست قطة ، على الأقل
لم يكن الغطاء  الحصول على لسانه
المارد معظم cnn نيويورك